Can you talk about the FADS genes, what the circle or minus three, and minus two mean?
So your FADS genes are, you know, it's right there on your, your genetic summary master
what they have to do, it really has to do with your ability to digest and utilize FAD
production.
I'm not going to read this to you.
But I think what this person is talking about is on your genetic summary, there's a
minus three, or a minus two, or a minus one, or a minus zero, or a plus one, or a plus
two, or a plus three, what does that mean?
That means how far off a variant of normal are you?
Now there's about 50,000 people that have put their genetics into this software.
So, obviously, other clinics other than us, out of that 50,000 people, where do you lie as far as
be, you know, how bad are these genes?
You could say it that way.
How bad are you with the FADS genes or any genes compared to the 50,000 people?
If you're in the minus, if you're at zero, you're equally the same as everybody else.
Here's a graph that you can't see on your chart, but here's a graph.
This is actually of your FADS genes.
So, if you're plus three, you're way over here.
This is you.
This is the need.
This is the average of those 50,000 people.
That means this is better.
You're way better than the 50,000 people.
So, if you are showing a minus side on any of those genes, that means you're better than the
mean of that population.
If you're showing a positive three, and you're really a lot worse than the average population.
So, far that you go away from the need is the number.
So, if you are a plus one, here's an example of somebody who is a negative two on something.
So, you're far on the left side of the need.
This is a different gene.
This is the FUT2 gene.
Flower on the left side of the main meaning.
This is something that you may want to address.
Your FUT2 genes have to do with gut function and gut healing.
So, this might be something you want to address.
Certainly with this, if you're in this, you don't need to do anything with your FADS genes.
You're doing great.
But here, this is a plus two, I think.
You are at, you know, much worse than, you're worse than the normal.
If you want to say that meat is normal, that is the normal of the population of the people that are in this software.
So, that's what the plus means, plus means you're actually on the negative side.
It's just how statistics are read, and minus means you're on the good side.
So, if you're at zero, minus one, plus one, yeah, not really too much to worry about,
whether you're at plus two, plus three, that's something you might want to address.